on
[Musique]
deux mois après les terribles
inondations qui ont frappé le pakistan à
rouge ou mayouns n'a pas une seconde à
lui
le magazine de l'humanitaire et des
solidarités ensemble solidaire sur votre
radio avec mm fiona tremblay jeune aaron
va accueillir ensemble si vous le voulez
bien à l'auge qui est secrétaire général
du centre culturel franco pakistanais
bonjour à
tous
aujourd'hui à ronger l'invité de radio
france maghreb en ce moment la vie de
cet informaticien d'origine pakistanaise
né en france il ya 29 ans est une
véritable course contre la montre
objectif mobiliser l'aide financière
promise au pakistan arrive au ralenti
l'eau est venu à vous souvenez a fait un
appel a fait un appel à tous ces pays
occidentaux riches et occidentaux pour
pour obtenir près de près de 500
millions de dollars on en est très loin
à rouge est triste et déçu il ne
comprend pas le manque de générosité
vis-à-vis de son pays d'origine 80% de
la population française refuse de faire
un don pour le pakistan mais 80% c'est
énorme et c'est énorme on sait pas
pourquoi mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que le pakistan leur a
fait directement mais si vous voulez pas
que ces 15 millions de survivants
périssent dans les mois à venir donc on
parle de 15 millions de morts la fois
jusqu'à maintenant en fait j'ai pas
envie que ça devienne 15 millions de
morts et que je les regarde en train de
mourir au quotidien c'est hallucinant
par tous les moyens à rouge tente de
pallier à l'incurie de l'état
pakistanais
son angoisse majeur c'est l'immense défi
sanitaire qui se profile à l'horizon
l'idée c'est bien sûr de d'émouvoir les
personnes qui se posent des questions de
savoir comment vont ses gens sur place
et bien moi je leur dis regardez les
photos parce que les photos parlent
d'elles mêmes on estime à 4 millions
d'enfants qui sont directement touchés
les risques d'épidémies sont évidemment
très grand c'est vraiment une question
de deux jours parce que si on
n'intervient pas rapidement ses enfants
que vous voyez allongé ici qui sont déjà
en très mauvaise situation
écoutez on pourrait on pourrait prévoir
le pire
c'est au centre culturel franco
pakistanais dans le xième que nous
retrouvons un rouge typiquement j'ai
peur pour celui là par exemple
puisqu'il est troué et que le scotch
n'est pas suffisamment bien mis donc bon
on va voir s'ils s'y passe pour pakistan
airlines ce soir un avion décolle
direction islamabad pakistan airlines la
compagnie nationale propose depuis
plusieurs semaines d'acheminer
gratuitement son fret contrainte de
taille aucun ramassage collectif des dos
du coup à rouge et ses amis scotch
emballé collecte un seul mot d'ordre
système des cas pas de structure
officiellement place c'est à dire que
les ong lors sans entrer dans le détail
n'ont pas la possibilité de stocker les
différents carton que les que les gens
leur leur apporte et donc nous on fait
un peu l'intermédiaire on fait un peu
comme on peu donc on substitue notre
bureau à un entrepôt donc ce qu'on a
demandé aux gens c'est prioriser denrées
alimentaires de l'eau il ya certainement
de glo aussi on verra tout à l'heure sur
les les listes et des médicaments très
important
tout est prêt photo m ca ici c'est grâce
à un ancien camion du samu prêté par son
ami monsieur radja carouge seront
maintenant à l'aéroport le nouvel orgue
ya pas d'autres solutions tous les
particuliers doivent venir jusqu'à cette
zone 4 de l'aéroport de roissy au sein
de cette cellule d'urgence pétition en
fait chaque semaine depuis deux mois les
avions de pakistan airlines d'école avec
40 tonnes de cartons remplis de produits
de première nécessité
chargé les soutes un véritable sacerdoce
pour un rouge c'est bon c'est bien sûr
le sur le directement si on met sur les
cartons le contenu
c'est dans la zone de fret numéro 4
carouge retrouve son ami arrive un
restaurateur parisien né au pakistan
arrive très impliqué dans la collecte de
dons est venu livrer 8 cartons qu'il a
lui-même confectionné j'ai de la famille
j'ai une cousine qui a été très touchée
tout leur village fête a été détruit
quasiment sa maison est en partie tombé
l'école de leur village étant mais aussi
je les appelle quasiment tous les jours
donc
juste après les inondations et locaux
lui et avec toute sorte d'épidémie à
deux de ses enfants du temps
pour arriver à rouge la journée a été
longue fatigués mais satisfaits de voir
leurs cartons s'envoler vers le pakistan
ça a été l'action
pour un rouge la quête n'est jamais fini
ce soir c'est dans le restaurant de son
pote à riffa châtelet qui l'a conduit 90
personnes pour un dîner de charité
on a mis un menu à 30 euros par personne
mais on a passé le message il faut pas
que les gens se limite à 30 euros
beaucoup de gens du verre des dons
ça je vous donnerai juste à ça va passer
avec différentes enveloppes de pouvoir
mettre vos contributions pour cette
soirée à l'intérieur merci ce soir la
diaspora pakistanais s'est mobilisé
autour d'un rouge bilan dix mille euros
un montant inespéré en france on compte
près de 80000 pakistanais alors à rouge
voit beaucoup plus loin
bien sûr ce pas avec ce qu'on va faire
ce soir on va trouver 40 milliards de
dollars faudra faudra faire en sorte que
dans les autres régions de france ils
essayent de faire la même chose à ce
rythme la reconstruction du pakistan
risquent d'être encore longue l'onu a
annoncé avoir récolté seulement 65% des
460 millions de dollars nécessaires aux
secours d'urgence alors les petites
mains comme celle d'à rouges sont les
bienvenus